okay so i'm sure by now you all know
what's going on
with voting in november we should vote
the act of voting itself
whether you vote in person or not has
become highly politicized my take is
everybody should vote you have the
opportunity to participate in deciding
who's going to lead our country i'm not
just talking about
trump versus biden i'm talking about the
local level i'm talking about the state
level
and you should exercise that right and
you should have a say so people have
written to me and they've said david
with all of this confusion about
absentee versus vote by mail please
explain how to vote by mail so first of
all
what we're talking about for november is
expanded absentee ballot access or you
might call it in some states
universal absentee voting in states that
have decided
to send ballots out they go only
to registered voters they don't go to
undocumented immigrants they don't go to
children
do not fall for those talking points
each state has its own rules
so you have to know the rules of your
state or commonwealth
so first of all figure out the rules in
your state go to the nass
website page called absentee and early
voting
we're linking to that page in the
description to the youtube clip for this
story
you put in your state for example when i
put in massachusetts
it takes me to the massachusetts
secretary of the commonwealth page
with information on how to get an
absentee ballot now massachusetts
sent out absentee ballot applications
automatically
i receive the application if i plan to
vote by mail which i do
i fill it out i send it back in and then
at some point after the september 1st
primary
once we know exactly who will be on the
ballot in november i will get the actual
absentee ballot which is where i vote
now
this is not the situation in every state
if you look at the brookings
map rating states on vote by mail
you will see that states range in
ratings from a to f
right now alabama is the only state
rated
f on absentee voting while a bunch of
states get an
a including the three west coast states
utah and colorado
hawaii and washington dc and then a
bunch of states
get a b and this relates to the ease
with which you can access an absentee
ballot in your particular state
now i wish i could tell you this is the
one way
to do this but each state runs things
differently so you actually do need to
go and look at your state's voting
website now a few things to understand
and again your state's website will tell
you this if you're in the commonwealth
of virginia or the state of florida or
even the state of florida as trump says
the every state and commonwealth has a
website that will explain this to you
in some states every registered voter
will get a ballot automatically
perfect just confirm you're registered
you can do that on the usa.gov
page confirm you're registered to vote
we're also linking to that if you're
registered and you're in a state that's
sending out
ballots to every registered voter
beautiful in other states
every registered voter will be sent an
application for a ballot
which you have to fill out and send in
in order to request
the actual ballot be sent to you that's
what i did in massachusetts for example
in some states you have to choose to go
and apply for an absentee ballot now
typically
i think there are some states where it
can be done online in other states you
have to send some physical piece of mail
to request the absentee ballot in some
states
everybody's allowed an absentee ballot
in
other states you have to give a valid
reason
for why you want to vote absentee and
depending on your state
saying i'm afraid of catching
coronavirus is considered a valid reason
now
in other states there's still a fight
going on about that so
you would have to look at the reasons
that are considered valid reasons for
requesting an absentee ballot in your
state
and match it to your situation i'm not
suggesting anybody lie but examine what
the valid reasons are
and determine whether any of them match
your
circumstances it's tragic that this is
what's going on
but all we can do given that voting
in some states starts in four and a half
weeks
is to go to your state's website if you
have to request something
do it now and stay on top of this this
really
isn't difficult and i understand when
you hear well am i getting a ballot or
am i getting an application
do i have to print the application or
can i fill it out online i get it
we have 50 different systems in the
united states
all of the links you need are in the
description to this youtube video clip
if anybody you know is at all confused
about how to vote by mail
send them this clip we did a story on
the bonus show where we discussed that
a whole bunch of people including in
particular young people
aren't sure how to vote by mail how to
request an absentee ballot or whether
they will get one automatically
that's exactly the confusion we are
trying to resolve here
figure out what's going on in your state
using the links provided in the
description for this youtube clip
it is not difficult you have a right to
vote in most states now
you have a right to vote absentee if you
go through the right process
take advantage of things that are
offered to you because the stakes quite
frankly could not be higher
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video